Prof: Very good.
So today we're going to talk
about phylogenetics and
systematics, and the lecture has
this kind of structure.
I'll remind you of what the
Tree of Life looks like.
Then I will motivate the
lecture basically by giving you
some surprising recent results
from molecular systematics,
and then I will go into
basically what phylogenetic
concepts are and how to build a
phylogenetic tree.
I won't do this in great
detail, but I hope I do enough
of it so that you at least have
a good feel for the issues that
are involved when you do this.
So this is the same picture of
the Tree of Life that I used
earlier in the course,
and basically it shows you that
since about 3.5 billion years
ago,
there have been three large
clades that have developed.
<<Technical
Adjustments>>
Take a moment and look at this
picture,
and look at the next one--which
is a--
this next one is essentially a
blowup of what's been going on
since about here--
and think about how much that
tells us about biology.
It provides a very basic
structure, the structure of
relationships.
It tells you which things
shared common ancestors,
and why we might expect them to
be one way rather than another
way.
It sets up thousands of
comparisons in our minds about
questions that we might ask.
It provides an extremely
useful, overarching structure.
But the question is,
how did phylogenetic biologists
actually get this picture,
and are they still changing it?
And the answer is:
they got it with the methods of
inference that I'm going to
sketch today,
and they're still changing it.
It's not written in stone and
it's been changing ever since
the first time somebody tried to
write it down.
So these things are working
hypotheses,
and we are able to get a better
and better refinement of them as
new information comes in,
but there are significant
changes.
Now this is what Darwin had to
say in the Origin about
the Tree of Life.
It's a truly wonderful fact,
the wonder of which we are apt
to overlook from familiarity,
that all animals and all
plants, throughout all time and
space,
should be related to each other
in groups.
And he goes on about how these
groups are hierarchical.
He said, "The affinities
of all the beings of the same
class have sometimes been
represented by a great tree.
I believe this simile is
largely the truth."
So in this beautiful Victorian
prose, Darwin rhapsodizes a bit
about the Tree of Life,
and it was the only picture he
had in his book.
Okay?
So he thought it was real
important.
He made a sketch of it,
and by it, by this sketch,
he meant to indicate that a lot
of things had gone extinct and
that through ancestry and shared
common ancestry you could define
relationship.
Now he could see immediately
that the tree isn't given,
it should be discovered.
He said, "Our
classifications will come to be,
as far as they can be so made,
genealogies;"
So they will reflect what
actually happened in terms of
evolutionary history to generate
relationship;
"and then they will truly
give what may be called the plan
of creation.
The rules for classifying will
no doubt become simpler when we
have a definite object in view.
We possess no pedigree or
armorial bearings."
Okay?
That's mid-nineteenth century
code for there's no barcode on
the species.
Okay?
They're not wearing their name
on the forehead and they're not
telling you who they're related
to.
So we have to discover and
trace these diverging lines.
Well it actually has taken a
long time for phylogenetics to
settle on clear logic and clear
methods.
Up until about oh somewhere
around 19--
the ideas were there but they
weren't really implemented until
about 1965 to 1970,
and there ensued a huge
controversy that lasted for
about twenty years.
And now that all--the dust has
settled and that seems to be in
the past,
but many people actually my age
are still marked by it,
because we witnessed it.
And I'm now going to more or
less summarize what came out of
it,
but I just want to signal to
you that this was,
in the not very distant past,
an extremely controversial area
of science,
and that it was revolutionized
both by the advent of DNA
sequence data,
and by the development of
powerful mathematical and
computer methods for determining
relationship;
and there was an argument about
which ones we should use.
So the first step in that is
taken by a guy named Zimmermann,
and it's just sketched here,
and it seems very simple:
Sharing a more recent common
ancestor defines relationship.
So magnolias and apple trees
are more closely related to each
other than either is to a
gingko,
because this point on the tree
is later in time,
and connects them,
than this point on the tree,
which connects them to gingkoes.
It seems like a very simple
idea.
It wasn't really clearly
articulated until Zimmermann
laid it down as a principle in
1931.
Now some of these concepts
you've already been through.
So I'm going to simply mention
these names again,
just so that they get repeated
and start becoming part of your
own vocabulary.
Monophyletic is a group that
contains all of the descendants
from a single common ancestor
and nothing that is not
descended from that common
ancestor;
paraphyletic groups are groups
that do not contain all of the
species descended from the most
recent common ancestor;
and polyphyletic groups really
are a hodgepodge of stuff that
shouldn't be in that sort of
bin,
under that category at all,
because they have--
basically independent
evolutionary lines are being
incorrectly lumped together.
The basis of a lot of this
inference is the concept of
homology,
and homology and analogy--I'll
repeat them in a minute when we
get to some slides that
illustrate them--
but they were defined by
Richard Owen in the early
nineteenth century,
before Darwin's Origin of
Species.
He was a great morphologist,
in London,
and basically the idea of
homology is that a trait is
identical in two or more species
because they are descended from
a common ancestor.
So they got it because their
ancestor had it.
And homoplasy,
or convergence,
is similarity for any reason
other than common ancestry.
So convergence in morphological
traits, mutation to the same
sequence, in DNA,
will lead to homoplasy.
So homology is helpful,
and homoplasy is confusing in
determining phylogenies.
So here's a good monophyletic
group.
Okay? This is the dogs.
And here the dogs are.
Here's Canis and Lycaon--so the
Lycaon is the African Hunting
Dog--and their closest relatives
are the South American wolves.
Canis, by the way,
Canis--the timber wolf is in
the genus Canis,
and all domestic dogs are
descended from wolves,
which is a nice example of
really rapid evolution;
take a wolf,
turn it into a Saint Bernard
and a Chihuahua.
I give you 5000 years.
Can you do it?
Well it takes pretty tough
breeding to do that,
but you can.
And, by the way,
I had a colleague--Armand
Kuris, who's at Santa Barbara,
decided he was going to create
his own race;
he wanted to create the ugliest
dog in the world.
He was going to name it the
Louisiana Swamp Dog.
It took him six generations.
I mean, this dog is really ugly.
>
But it's registered with the
American Kennel Club.
So you can do rapid breeding
with dogs.
That's, of course,
on a timescale up here that you
couldn't even fit onto that
little white line at the top of
the picture.
Interestingly,
all this stuff over here is
extinct.
There are a few little marks
here that are kind of
interesting.
Out here, on the branch going
up to the Caninae,
is digitigrady,
which means that at that point
they started chasing after
things that were running fast,
and evolution,
just like it did with horses,
started to cause them to be
selected to run on their toes.
So they got longer legs by
running on their toe tips,
rather than on the pads of
their feet directly.
And bone cracking came in right
about here, so they could get
the marrow out of bones.
That's a good monophyletic
group.
You probably can't see it up
there.
I'll give you a little bit of
timeline.
The whole thing starts taking
off about 40,000,000 years ago,
in the Eocene.
And Canis, the dog genus
itself, is about 5,000,000 years
old;
it's about as old as Homo.
Okay, here are some
paraphyletic groups.
Reptiles is paraphyletic.
Okay?
It's got turtles,
lizards and crocodiles in it,
but it doesn't have the birds.
So reptiles is an inaccurate
term.
This is the monophyletic
group--lizards,
crocodiles and birds--and we
don't have an everyday language
term for it.
Crocodiles, by the way,
build nests and guard them,
and when the baby crocodiles
hatch out,
they cheep like birds:
"cheep,
cheep."
So there are--this relationship
between crocs and birds is well
established.
Here's a polyphyletic group.
If we define a group called the
homoeothermic tetrapods,
it contains the birds and the
mammals.
But look at all of the things
that are more closely related to
the birds than the mammals are.
So if we were to define the
birds and the mammals as a
group,
it would be a false group,
because phylogenetically the
birds have many things which are
more closely related to them
than the mammals do.
And this group is polyphyletic.
Okay?
It has contributions from two
different sources.
Another good example of a
polyphyletic group would be if
you decided to link together all
of the things that look like
cactuses in Africa and South
America.
The ones in South America are
cactuses, but the ones in Africa
are euphorbs;
they look just like cactuses.
There's a nice example in the
Peabody Museum.
You can look at them sitting
next to each other.
Okay?
That's a polyphyletic group.
They are convergent,
they came together.
Similarly, the homeothermy in
the birds and mammals is
convergent.
The ancestor back here did not
have warm blood.
It evolved twice,
once in the line to mammals and
once in the line to birds.
I know there were some-warm
blooded dinosaurs,
but that was later.
Warm-bloodedness probably came
in, in this line,
about here somewhere;
don't know exactly.
Then this central concept,
homology.
Here are the forelimbs of
turtles, humans,
horses, birds,
bats and seals.
So we've got some stuff here
that's spanning quite a bit of
the tetrapods;
vertebrates that are living on
land.
And you can see that it's
possible to match up sections of
these structures,
all the way through.
And actually if you study that,
and you realize that they were
all in an ancestral condition
together,
you can see how evolution has
changed their proportions,
changed their thickness,
but it hasn't changed their
spatial relationships to each
other.
And, in fact,
if you go through the
development,
you'll discover that the same
nerves coming out of the
backbone are running to the same
parts of the limb,
and all of those conditions
have been held together,
over evolutionary time.
And if you look at the HOX
genes that are controlling their
development,
you can see,
as you saw in a lecture a
little bit earlier,
that the DNA sequences in the
HOX genes,
that are telling it whether to
make a humerus,
a radius, an ulna or digits,
are actually homologous in
their DNA sequence as well.
So there's a molecular homology
that underlies the morphological
homology.
And if you look at molecular
sequences,
here's a gene called aniridia
in humans,
and a gene called eye-less in
fruit flies,
and only six--these are not DNA
sequences,
this is protein sequence;
so these are amino acids--only
six of the sixty amino acids are
different.
The two sequences are 90%
identical.
There are search algorithms,
like BLAST, that go out and
look for these sorts of
similarities.
So that if you get a candidate
gene or a candidate protein
sequence,
it's possible simply to put a
search term in,
to a search engine,
and have other genes from other
species pop up.
So you can look for molecular
homology that way.
A good molecular homology is
the fruit fly homeobox complex
and the human HOX complex--
we talked about this
earlier--where the sequence of
the genes along the chromosome,
and the parts of the body that
are being controlled by those
genes developmentally,
are similar in humans and in
fruit flies,
and actually unite everything
that you see here.
So this sort of thing is a
signal of shared ancestry,
and it's the kind of molecular
information used to construct
the broader Tree of Life.
So this is something that is
linking together arthropods,
annelids, mollusks,
echinoderms and chordates.
Now analogy.
Analogy or convergence is a
misleading kind of information,
because that means that natural
selection has taken things that
were evolutionarily independent,
and which have sister groups,
have relatives,
that don't look anything like
this,
and then shaped both of those
things to come together to a
common form.
So the dolphin and the
ichthyosaur have a very similar
fusiform body,
and this is because of strong
selection to swim rapidly in the
ocean and to chase down fish and
squid;
which they both did.
And the analogy goes deeper
than that.
As you probably know,
the dolphin has live birth,
it's viviparous.
So is the ichthyosaur.
If you go to a striking museum,
just south of Tübingen,
in Germany, and look at the
world's largest collection of
pregnant ichthyosaurs,
you can see an ichthyosaur that
was giving birth at the point
when it was fossilized.
And they often had twins,
or triplets.
So the definition of analogy is
two things that look very much
alike,
even though they have many
relatives that look quite
different and are distant on the
tree.
So the dolphin is more closely
related to a kangaroo than it is
to an ichthyosaur,
and an ichthyosaur is more
closely related to a hummingbird
than it is to a dolphin;
nevertheless they look similar.
So that's analogy.
So once people got their DNA
sequences and their logic under
control,
and they started doing a lot of
molecular systematics,
they discovered some
relationships that were kind of
surprising,
because analogy,
convergence,
had been covering up
relationship,
or because evolution had so
radically changed the external
appearance of these creatures,
that it was very difficult to
see who they were related to.
Here are a few of these
insights.
I'll bet that if I ask Alex or
Jeremy or Katie or the other
teaching fellows if they've got
a favorite one,
that they could probably come
up with others as well.
Maybe I will in a minute;
so start thinking.
Okay?
Pentastomids were a mysterious
group of creatures,
and they turn out to be closely
related to fish lice.
I'll show you a pentastomid in
a minute.
There used to be a group called
carnivorous plants,
the pitcher plants and the
sundews,
and people thought that the
pitcher plants and the sundews
were related.
These are plants that are
adapted to living under very low
nitrogen conditions,
and they need nitrogen to make
all of their proteins,
and they get it by killing
insects and other things.
Some of them can even kill a
small frog.
So it was thought that it was
likely that this was a natural
group and that they had all
evolved these capacities in an
ancestral condition,
and that they were all related
to each other.
But they're not.
It's happened several times.
It wasn't really clear where
the whales had come from.
One might have thought that
well maybe whales are related to
seals, or perhaps they're
related to other aquatic
mammals, like otters.
But seals and otters are
carnivores,
and it turns out that whales,
including the toothed whales,
the active carnivorous dolphins
and sperm whales,
are ungulates.
Okay?
So there was an ungulate that
used go around eating plants and
it went into the water and it
started to eat all kinds of
other things.
Okay?
It stopped eating plants and it
started eating fish,
squid;
and some of them eat a lot of
crustacea, if they filter feed.
Sycamores.
Sycamores, or plane trees,
are the classic tree which is
used to decorate the European
plaza.
Okay?
If you like to sit out in the
summer, in Italy or France,
and watch the people go by,
you're probably sitting under a
sycamore tree.
And they have a leaf that looks
like a maple leaf,
and if you just look at a
sycamore--and by the way it has
a kind of blotchy bark;
so it has sort of white bark
but with blotches on it--
if you just look at a sycamore
and you just look at the shape
of the leaf,
you might think,
"Oh, these are related to
maples."
They aren't at all.
They are in fact more closely
related to water lilies.
Now those are some pretty
radical surprises.
Those are things that were
buried in the DNA sequences,
that were not apparent in the
morphology,
and they are not only testimony
to the power of molecular
systematics,
they are testimony to the power
of natural selection to change
the shape of things in ways that
are profoundly altering and
create all sorts of
mis-impressions about
relationship.
So here are some pentastomids.
This set of pentastomid worms
here is actually crawling across
the roof of a crocodile's mouth.
They tend to live in the noses
of crocodiles and dogs.
They don't tend to live in
humans, this is one of those
yucky, creepy-crawlies that you
don't have to worry about too
much yourself.
But it looks--actually it looks
something like a beetle larva,
or something like that;
it looks kind of like a
mealworm.
But look, it's got segments in
it, and it has some kind of
funny structure inside.
It turns out that it's most
closely related to this thing.
Here is a fish louse on the
outside of a triggerfish,
and this is an isopod.
Pentastomids are related to
fish lice.
They are not related to
beetles, or to nematode worms,
or to a lot of other things.
And, in fact,
they're nested within the fish
lice.
So evolution took something
that looked like that and turned
it into that.
And like a lot of things,
this probably was accomplished
by things like crocodiles eating
things like fish.
And when the parasite that was
living on the fish got ingested
by the crocodile,
it was more or less,
"Oh my heavens,
how am I going to adapt to the
crocodile?"
Well if it could fall of the
fish and stay in the mouth of
the crocodile and crawl up its
nose, it can survive;
which essentially is what these
things did.
Here are two carnivorous plants.
Okay? They are polyphyletic.
Pitcher plants have evolved
independently at least three
times;
flypaper traps at least five
times.
There are two groups of pitcher
plants that are sister groups to
two clades of flypaper traps;
but others have other sister
groups.
So these are actually deeply
cool plants.
The world hotspot of pitcher
plants,
if you have a deep desire to go
collect a lot of pitcher plants,
is Borneo, and it is no
coincidence that Borneo is an
island that has very,
very nitrogen poor soil,
and the trees and all the
shrubs that live on Borneo,
many of them have special
adaptations to dealing with this
low nutrient environment.
Things like flypaper and the
sundews, the flypaper traps,
they often live in bogs,
which also are extremely
nutrient poor.
If you go to Bethany Bog here,
you will find these living in
Bethany Bog.
It's a kettle lake that was
left after the glaciers
retreated.
There's a mat of vegetation
growing out over it,
which means that in the middle
of it, the plants are living
right over water.
The water is nutrient poor,
and there are flypaper traps
catching flies out there,
to get their protein.
This is a chunk of the Tree of
Life that shows you the
radiation of the ungulates.
And you can see that both the
toothed and the baleen whales
are nested within the ungulates,
and their closest relatives are
the hippos.
So you should think that the
ancestor of the hippo went into
the ocean,
probably about 35,000,000 years
ago,
and right here,
marked on the tree,
are some of the genes which
have changed along these
particular lines and which are
signals of those relationships.
So the take-home point is that
appearances are deceptive and
detective work is needed.
Now how do you do the detective
work?
How do you build a phylogenetic
tree?
Before I do that,
do you guys have any favorite
sort of phylogenetic--you have;
Jeremy what's yours?
Teaching Fellow:
Yes, gnetales,
not being related to flowering
plants, for me personally.
Because gnetales have double
fertilization,
which is a very interesting
innovation of plants,
or flowering plants have.
And actually ginkgos are
gnetales in the gymnosperms,
the pine trees.
That personally--we learned
that from Burleigh and Mathews .
Prof: So how recently
was that discovered?
Teaching Fellow:
Like three years ago;
three or four years ago.
Prof: Okay,
see, the tree keeps changing.
It's a moving target.
It gets better.
The basic branches are not
moving too much,
but out there on the tips
there's still a lot of action.
So how do you get it?
How do you build a phylogenetic
tree?
Well this is an important point.
You need to have some
characters;
so those are states of traits.
They could be nucleotide
sequences.
It could be whether the thing
has scales or fur,
or it could be whether it has a
three or four-chambered heart.
It could be a lot of things.
So you need characters,
and they need to have different
states.
And the characters that are
informative are shared derived
characters.
I will go into this issue with
a full slide,
because this is a key point;
the characters that give you
phylogenetic information are the
ones that everything in a group
shares with each other,
and it's different from the
ancestor.
Well, you can only define
derived by comparison with
primitive.
Okay?
So primitive is like what it
used to be, and derived is what
it is now, somewhere on the
tree, and you can't do that
without a tree.
So there's kind of a paradox.
You don't have a tree,
and if you don't have it,
you don't have a way to
determine what came first,
and therefore you don't know
about character polarization.
Character polarization means
knowing which state is primitive
and which is derived;
that polarizes that series of
trait states.
So there are number of ways out
of this logical dilemma.
One is you look at all possible
trees--
this is, by the way,
a huge computational problem,
as you'll see at the end--and
you choose the ones that are
simplest.
So that's the principle of
parsimony.
And it's a logical principle;
it's not an empirical
principle, and it's not
necessarily the way that
evolution operates.
But given that there are many,
many possible trees,
choosing the simplest one
basically is a way of saying,
"This is how we're dealing
with our ignorance."
Or you could choose the tree
that would make it most likely
that you would have observed the
character data that you actually
did observe;
that's called the principle of
maximum likelihood.
And, in fact,
in the computer programs and in
the theoretical arguments that
go on in phylogenetics,
these are two of the main
themes, and many of the methods
combine them,
in various ways.
Okay, so a bit about
shared-derived characters.
Remember that picture with the
different colors,
with the different parts of the
forelimb?
Having a forelimb that has a
humerus,
a radius, an ulna,
carpals and metacarpals,
in that sequence,
really doesn't help us to
distinguish bats from turtles.
Okay?
That trait's shared among all
tetrapods.
So the fact that you're looking
at a thing, that's got those
parts to it, doesn't help you to
distinguish bats from turtles
from whales from seals.
Sure, they've all got it,
but that's not telling you
whether they're closely related
to each other or not,
because they all got it from a
common ancestor;
it's not derived.
However, that structure
distinguishes the tetrapods from
the lobe-finned fishes.
So at that point on the tree it
becomes useful as a
shared-derived marker,
of a group;
which is why,
one of the reasons why,
we're pretty confident that the
tetrapods is a good group,
and that things didn't- that
the vertebrates didn't come out
of the water multiple times.
In this context it's marking a
trait that originated once in
their common ancestor;
it's shared by all of them;
it's not found in their closest
relatives.
The jargon is derived from the
Greek.
This thing is called a
synapomorphy.
Syn means shared;
apo means derived;
and morph means trait.
So a shared-derived trait is a
synapomorphy.
Now there's a bunch of
important stuff here.
Just looking the same isn't
very helpful.
The informative traits are the
ones that are shared and
derived.
And what is shared and what is
derived, and therefore what is
informative, depends on the
context;
it depends on the part of the
tree that you're sitting in.
Okay, now a little bit about
building trees.
You can think--evolution is
real complex and a lot of stuff
is going on.
But let's suppose that A has
the ancestral state of a trait,
and that between A and B and C,
a new state of the trait
evolves.
So Ancestral is blue and New is
red.
And this marks the point where
that trait started to change,
and then it spread through the
population and by this point it
was fixed.
Well this is a cartoon,
and this is a cartoon of a
cartoon.
Okay?
We're just marking where that
happened, and the only important
thing about this mark is that it
is between this point and this
point;
other than that,
we don't really know exactly
where it is.
Okay?
Now A, B and C would normally
be species.
Okay?
But they could be other things.
They could be genes,
or they could be genera or
families or something like that.
And 1,2, and 3 are characters.
They could be morphological;
they could be molecular.
And, as a convention,
the ancestral state of that
character will be denoted 0,
and the derived state will be
denoted 1;
and the arrow indicates going
from ancestral to derived.
And basically what this picture
is telling you is that Trait 1
changed from ancestral to
derived,
between A and B,
and then after B split off from
C,
two more things changed in C.
Okay, so that's the information
that picture is trying to give
you.
And if you put down a real
interesting vertebrate
phylogeny,
like this, a vertebrate
phylogeny which has some
unfortunate names,
for certain groups on it--okay?;
like reptiles aren't real--and
we use these characters,
having a vertebral column,
having lungs,
having an amniotic egg,
having lactation,
eggshell absent,
chorioallantoic placenta,
hooves on distal phalanges,
a petrosal bulla,
in the skull,
then what we can see from
plotting those along the line
basically is which characters
here are distinguishing which
groups;
what's going on when you go out
into the ungulates,
the horses and the cows.
The vertebral column is a
synapomorphy of the vertebrates,
of this whole bunch here.
But if we just look at the
mammals, which are from here on
out, it's an ancestral trait;
it's not a derived trait,
it's a shared-primitive trait,
and that's a symplesiomorphy,
not a synapomorphy.
The lungs, which come in right
here, at 2, are a synapomorphy
of the tetrapods,
but they are an ancestral
trait, a symplesiomorphy of the
amniotes;
okay, so the amniotes are back
here--excuse me,
the amniotes are up here.
So whether you call a trait one
or the other depends on where it
sits in the tree and what it
allows you to do with it.
This is a bit of the
relationship between trees and
names.
Ideally we would like that
relationship to be totally clear
and unambiguous so that if I
just give you a name,
you know where that thing sits
in the tree.
This is a hard thing to do.
It is so hard to do that there
is now a complete overturning of
the Linnaean System of
Classification going on.
It's being led by a couple of
guys here, Michael Donoghue and
Jacques Gauthier.
Michael is in our department,
and he's also vice-president of
the university,
and Jacques Gauthier is a prof
in G&G - in Paleontology.
And they have worked a lot on
how to get a way to name things
that actually tells you their
complete position on the Tree of
Life.
Okay?
It's going to be a big computer
code.
It's not going to be something
nice like Homo sapiens.
Okay?
Homo sapiens is the Linnaean
name.
The new method will contain a
lot more information in it,
and will probably only be
something that you can store on
your iPhone,
or whatever else it is that you
use to replace your memory.
But ideally these terms would
map onto natural relationships;
and these terms actually do map
onto these natural
relationships.
Okay?
So this is the primates,
and these are the ungulates,
and they are nested within the
eutherian mammals.
The therian mammals include the
marsupials, and the mammals
include the monotremes,
which are the spiny echidna and
the duckbilled platypus.
And between them and the
marsupials is where the female
reproductive tract evolved,
because the monotremes are
still laying eggs.
And then the amniotes would
include the so-called reptiles;
that would actually be
crocodiles, lizards,
snakes, turtles.
The tetrapods include the
amphibians, and then the
vertebrates include the fish,
as well.
So this is a natural
classification,
and that's the way all
taxonomic nomenclature should be
related to all good systematics.
Now, how do you actually infer
a tree from a character matrix?
So here we're just trying to
figure out if things are related
or not.
We don't have a tree yet.
Okay?
And we have three species and
we have three characters;
and in this case ancestral is
going to be 0 and 1 is going to
be derived.
Well this particular character
matrix is consistent with
drawing a tree this way,
and then marking down the
transitions here.
So when 1 went from ancestral
to derived, it changed here in
both B and C,
and when 2 and 3 went from
ancestral to derived,
it changed only in C.
So can you see how the tree
relates to the matrix?
Okay?
Any question about that at this
point?
I've made the simplest one I
could.
Now if we did it with overall
similarity, A and B share five
ancestral counts.
Okay?
In three traits,
1,2 and 3, A has got the
ancestral state.
In two traits,
two of those,
in B--B has also got the
ancestral trait in 2 and 3,
and that would suggest this
tree.
But if we go by derived
similarity, then we get this
tree.
And you can see what it does to
the tree.
So this is overall similarity,
which is misleading,
and this is shared derived
trait phylogenetics,
which yields this tree,
and it shifts the sister of B
from A to C.
Now if life were only so simple.
Life is never simple.
Traits can conflict with each
other in the information they
give you, and they often do.
So here is a character matrix
with no conflict,
and here's a character matrix
with conflict.
Okay?
So everything was looking
pretty good, as long as we'd
only measured Trait 1 and 2 down
here.
But then we measured Trait 3,
and Trait 3 seemed to indicate
that C had this ancestral trait
over here.
It was beginning to look like C
was going to be a highly derived
species.
But then we've looked at
another trait and it wasn't like
that.
What do you do?
Right?
Well you can choose the
simplest tree.
You can choose the one that
implies the least change.
So here are all trees which are
consistent with this character
matrix.
And if you go back and try,
I think you will see that you
can plot all of these changes
onto here.
So basically this tree is
saying that third trait down
here, it changed twice;
it changed once in A and it
changed once in B.
So it went from an ancestral
state up to a derived state,
along these branches.
And these traits up here,
1 and 2, they changed between
A, on the one hand,
and B and C on the other,
here.
So you could do that also,
and you would find that all of
these trees are actually
consistent with that character
matrix,
but this one takes five changes
and these only take 4:
1,2, 3,4;
1,2, 3,4, 5.
Therefore, we come to the
conclusion that one of these
traits, one of these trees,
is probably correct,
just by the principle of
parsimony.
And the only way that we really
resolve this kind of issue is by
getting more data.
The more data you get,
the more likely it is that that
will converge on the real tree.
I would like to point out that
there probably is not enough
data in the world to do that,
for all of the creatures on the
planet.
In other words,
at the end of the process there
will still be some unresolved
stuff.
Now what about--let me just put
that in--what about this?
Where does the root come from?
Well these are unrooted trees,
up here,
and the choice of where you
decide the ancestral state is
actually makes quite a bit of
difference to the tree.
I'm sorry that in translating
this has gotten screwed up a
little bit here.
This is actually A over here,
and then it goes D,
B, C over here.
Choosing this as the root,
rather than this,
changes the relationship from B
and D to B and C;
this is B and this is C;
this is B and this is D.
So where do you get the
outgroup, how do you decide
where the root should be?
Well, that issue can only be
decided in the context of a
bigger tree.
So you must have some other
kind of information to suggest
what your out group might be.
And, when this is actually
done, sometimes people see
whether the choice of an
outgroup is actually going to be
changing the shape of their tree
very much.
They will report,
"We tried this and this
and this as the out group,
and these were the results,
to our tree."
Okay?
Now, you get your trait matrix,
you want to find the simplest
tree.
One of them is to do an
exhaustive search.
So here are two terminal taxa,
B and C.
Okay?
We've chosen A as the ancestral
condition;
it's not an existing species
now.
A, we say, is going to be the
out group;
that's going to be link to the
ancestors.
Only one tree possible.
If we have three terminal taxa,
we can have either B as the
closest relative of D;
C as the closest relative of D;
or B and C as being their
closest relative.
So there are three
possibilities there.
If we have four terminal taxa,
oh my goodness,
suddenly we have this many.
Oh that's confusing.
If we have 500 terminal taxa,
we have 1 times 10^(1280
)possibilities.
This is a combinatorial
explosion of possibilities.
And about, oh say about
2003,2004,
it took nine months of runtime
on a supercomputer to sort out
all of the possible trees for a
reasonable number of characters
for something like this.
So if you have 500 species and
you wanted--
and you had a reasonable number
of characters,
you would only get a tiny
fraction of those trees covered,
and you would wait nine months
to get your answer.
It's gotten a little better
than that recently,
but not much.
Okay?
So there are ways to get around
this problem.
There are all kinds of
heuristic ways to get around
this.
There are ways of jumping into
tree space and doing local
approximations and then
branching things together.
So that, for example,
when the New York Times
reported last week,
on Darwin's birthday,
that biologists had recently
been able to publish a tree of
11,000 plant species,
which was done here,
by Stephen Smith and Michael
Donoghue's group;
he did that as a super-tree,
using these approximation
techniques to patch together
lots of smaller trees.
And there are all kinds of
criteria that get applied to how
good that is.
By the way, one of the things
that Stephen turned up is that
hey, the ferns are still
evolving rapidly;
which is kind of neat.
Lots of other stuff is in that.
So, the Tree of Life is not
given.
We have to discover it.
The informative characters in
the Tree of Life are those that
are shared and derived.
So appearances deceive.
Simply looking similar is
insufficient information.
You can make a lot of trees
with the same character matrix.
You would prefer either the
simplest,
which implies the least change,
or the tree that maximizes the
probability of observing what
you actually see,
or some combination of those
criteria.
Okay?
Next time we'll take these
methods and see how we can infer
history with them.